>> Greg: ANOTHER HEADACHE FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN ON THE FOREIGN
POLICY FRONT.
REPORTS CHINA CAUGHT U.S.
INTELLIGENCE BY SURPRISE AFTER
TESTING A HYPERSONIC MISSILE
THAT IS SO FAST IT CAN EVADE
AMERICA'S DEFENSE CAPABILITIES.
WHITE HOUSE BEING CRITICIZED FOR
ITS RESPONSE THAT IT "WELCOMED
STIFF COMPETITION," AND CHINA
DENIES IT TESTED THE MISSILE AND
SAID IT WAS A SPACECRAFT.
GOP SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM ISN'T
BUYING IT.
>> YOU CAN NOW PUT ON THE LIST
NUCLEAR ARMS RACE WITH CHINA,
WHICH WE'RE LOSING.
WEAKNESS BREEDS AGGRESSION.
>> Harold: ADDING TO THE
PROBLEMS, NORTH KOREA TEST FIRED
SUBMARINE LAUNCH BALLISTIC
MISSILE.
KATIE, IS IT NOT BIPARTISAN
FAILURE ON THIS FRONT WITH
CHINA, NORTH KOREA, I WAS IN
CONGRESS WHEN WE WERE ATTACKED
ON 9/11, IT WAS BIPARTISAN LACK
OF IMAGINATION.
I GET PARTISANSHIP, WHAT SHOULD
WE BE DOING DIFFERENTLY NOW THAT
WE KNOW THIS?
>> Katie: PRESIDENT BIDEN HASN'T
GIVEN ANY INDICATION HE IS
WILLING TO STAND UP FOR THE
COUNTRY.  THE PRESS SECRETARY
SAID WE WELCOMED THE
COMPETITION, WHEN THIS IS A
SERIOUS WEAPON GENERALS SAY
CHANGES THE GAME WHEN IT COMES
TO HOW WE LOOK AT NUCLEAR
DETERRENCE, WHETHER WE HAVE A
FIRST-STRIKE OPTION ANYMORE.
WITH ALLIES, QUESTIONING JOE
BIDEN'S CAPABILITIES, ESPECIALLY
IN THE AFTERMATH OF AFGHANISTAN,
THEY'RE LOOKING AT THIS AND
GOING, IF THE UNITED STATES IS
BEHIND DEFENDING ITSELF ON
MISSILE LAUNCH THAT IS
SUPERSONIC, THEY ARE BEHIND WITH
BANNING WITH NATIONS LIKE
TAIWAN, FOR EXAMPLE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN MADE DECISION TO
LEAVE AFGHANISTAN, A LOT OF
AMERICANS AND INTELLIGENCE AND
FOREIGN POLICY EXPERTS SAID IT
WAS A GOOD IDEA, IN ORDER TO
FOCUS ON THREATS LIKE CHINA AND
NORTH KOREA.
WHETHER OR NOT HE'S CAPABLE OF
SHIFTING AND DOING THAT, HE
HASN'T GIVEN THAT PUBLICLY YET
AND IDEA THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY IS SURPRISED ON THIRD
MAJOR THING IN THE LAST NINE
MONTHS, CONCERNS A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
>> Harold: DANA, YOU HAVE BEEN
IN THE WHITE HOUSE WHEN THINGS,
YOU HAD TO REACT AND ADJUST,
WHAT SHOULD SHE HAVE DONE
DIFFERENTLY?
WHAT SHOULD THEY BE TALKING
ABOUT IN TERMS OF MESSAGING AND
AFTER ADMITTING THEY WERE
SURPRISED --
>> Dana: I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
SOME -- SOMEONE DO A MEDIA
INTERVIEW OR MAYBE CONGRESSIONAL
HEARING, BORING, BUT I THINK IF
YOU ARE GIVING INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY X BILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR AND THE QUOTE ANONYMOUS
QUOTE IS WHOA, WHAT HAPPENED, WE
HAD NO IDEA THIS IS GOING ON.
WE DESERVE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE INVESTMENT IS HOW WE COULD
MISS SOMETHING SO OBVIOUS AS
THIS AND MAKES YOU WONDER WHAT
ELSE ARE WE MISSING.
THE ADVERSARIES WILL CONTINUE TO
TEST US.
OUR COMPLETE AND TOTAL FOREIGN
POLICY FOCUS UNDER BIDEN IS
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE.
EVERYTHING THEY ARE FOCUSED ON,
MEETING AT END OF THIS MONTH IN
GLASGOW, THEY WANT TO GO AND
PASS POLICIES.
THEY ARE NOT PAYING ATTENTION TO
THIS, THEY ARE JUST BLOWING IT
OFF.
>> Harold: JESSE, PRESIDENT
TRUMP USH ERRED AND DEMANDED
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO CHINA.
I GIVE HIM CREDIT FOR THAT.
I DON'T THINK HE DID MUCH
SUBSTANTIVELY, I THINK IT IS
BIPARTISAN FAILURE.
IF NOT, WHERE DO YOU GIVE CREDIT
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP AND PRESIDENT
BIDEN AND WHAT SHOULD WE BE
DOING?
>> Jesse: AS I SAID YESTERDAY, I
GIVE BIDEN CREDIT FOR THE
ALLIANCE BETWEEN THE U.K. AND
AUSTRALIA, AGAINST CHINA, EVEN
THOUGH HE DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT.
I GIVE TRUMP CREDIT FOR WAKING
THIS COUNTRY UP ABOUT CHINA.
IT EXPLODES OVER LOS ANGELES,
GOODBYE LOS ANGELES, IT IS LIKE
STRATEGIC DETERRENT, IT IS NOT
TACTICAL.
THEY ARE WARPING US, WE CAN WIPE
OUT SEATTLE, SAN FRANCISCO AND
YOU HAVE 30 SECONDS TO INTERCEPT
THIS THING, THAT IS TOUGH.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO NOW, GO TO
STAR WARS, CONFRONT SOMETHING
LIKE THIS.
THAT WAY, YOU SHOOT THE THING
OUT OF THE SKY MIDFLIGHT AS IT
DIPS BELOW THE ORBIT LEVEL AND
THAT IS HOW YOU TAKE IT OUT.
IT IS INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE TO DO
"STAR WARS" AND JOE'S TEAM IS
MORE INTERESTED IN THE GREEN NEW
DEAL, HEVILLE TO MAKE A DECISION
WHETHER HE WANTS TO DO THAT OR
NOT AND THERE IS GOOD NEWS HERE.
THIS IS JUST ONE THAT WAS 20
MILES OFF IN THE TEST --
>> Harold: EXPERTS SAID WAS
PRETTY GOOD.
>> Jesse: 20 MILES OFF IS A LONG
WAY, COULD TAKE FIVE YEARS TO
GET THE PROGRAM OPERATIONAL AND
WE ARE 50 YEARS AHEAD OF CHINESE
WHEN IT COMES TO THE NUCLEAR
ARMS RACE AND WE COULD SPLATTER
CHINA WITH NUCLEAR WEAPONS, NOT
WORRIED ABOUT THAT.  BIG CHING
WITH CHINA, POPULATION IS OVER.
THEY HAVE SLOWEST GROWING
POPULATION IN WORLD HISTORY,
BECAUSE THEY KILLED ALL THE
WOMEN, THERE ARE NO WOMEN IN THE
COUNTRY AND BECAUSE OF
URBANNIZATION, THEY WILL LOSE
50% BY 2050.
WAIT THESE GUYS OUT AND HOPE
THEY DON'T LAUNCH A MISSILE LIKE
THIS.
>> GREG, WE SPENT A LOT OF
MONEY.
A LOT CAME OUT, WALL CAME DOWN,
COMMUNISM SUFFERED DEFEAT, NEW
TECHNOLOGY EMERGED, SHOULD WE
MARSHALL THE SAME KIND OF EFFORT
OR ATTRACT SUPPORT FROM COUNTRYS
TO GO AGAINST CHINA FROM
ECONOMIC STANDPOINT, MILITARY
STANDPOINT?
AND TO JESSE'S POINT, WEVILLE TO
AS COUNTRY UNDERSTAND THAT
DEFENSE SPENDING WILL HAVE TO GO
WAY UP AND WE'LL HAVE TO THINK
MORE IMAGINATIVELY HOW WE DEFEND
OURSELVES.
>> Greg: YOU ARE TOO
PESSIMISTIC.
I KNOW THE ROCKET IS ALARMING,
BUT WE ARE KICKING THE CRAP OUT
OF CHINA IN DIVERSITY, GENDER
NEUTRAL BATHROOMS AND WE HAVE
WAY MORE WINDMILLS THAN THEY DO.
>> Dana: THEY BUILD THEM FOR US.
>> Greg: TRUE, AND SOLAR PANELS.
I DON'T THINK CHINA WILL BOMB US
ANY TIME SOON, THEY DON'T NEED
TO, WE ARE ENJOYING OURSELVES.
CHINA JUST EXPOSED FOLLY OF US.
FOR US, IT IS DISMANTLED THE
SUPER POWER THAT IS US, RIGHT?
WE ARE OUR OWN ENEMY NOW,
INITIATING DESTRUCTION FROM
WITHIN.
CHINA WILL SIMPLY WAIT US OUT
UNTIL WE'RE FINISHED.  THE
NUMBER ONE ENEMY IN AMERICA IS
AMERICA.
AND IT IS NOT ALL JOE'S FAULT.
CHINA HAS THE ADVANTAGE OF NOT
BEING SADDLED ACADEMIC
ESTABLISHMENT THAT HATES ITS OWN
COUNTRY.
THEY DON'T PRODUCE SOCIAL
JUSTICE WARRIORS THAT WANT TO
DISMANTLE THIS WORLD AND BRING
US BACK TO THE DARK AGES.
CHINA SMARTLY ENCOURAGES WOKISM
IN THE BUSINESSES THEY DO WORK
WITH FROM AMERICA, BECAUSE THEY
KNOW IT HANDICAPS OUR COUNTRY.
THEY ARE JUST DOING WHAT THEY
ARE SUPPOSED TO DO, THEY KNOW WE
ARE ON TRAJECTORY, BEYOND NAVAL
GAZING, WE HAVE OUR HEADS WAY UP
THERE.
>> Harold: YOU ARE RIGHT.
THEY DON